so
thank you to the welcome to the press
conference
following the second day of the european
council
welcome and thank you for joining us um
i see there a lot of people
already raising a hand but i'll first
give the floor to the president
of the european council
merci beaucoup
that we addressed today is the
coordination
related to the kovit 19 crisis you know
that our goal is to limit the spread
of the virus it means it is important to
make more progress
between the member states with the
support of the commission with the
support
of the rotating presidency and we have
worked a lot uh the recent weeks the
recent
days as well on that we took the
decision
to strengthen our coordination our
cooperation on the basis of the concrete
proposals
put on the table by the commission and
risk involvement of the rotating
presidency and we took also the decision
uh to
make more effort in order to to to work
together
uh in the perspective of the vaccines
the commission had the occasion
to explain with details what we are
trying to do
together as a european union in order to
be able
when vaccines will be available to make
to make sure
that it will be possible for the
different member states in europe but
also
for our partners to have access to
those vaccines which in our opinion
should be considered
as a common good it was a launch a
substantive
distribution and we agreed that we will
have the occasion uh
during our next european conceals uh to
come back again on this very
important uh topic this is one first
point
another important point at the occasion
this morning
to present to the colleagues the leaders
agenda for the next month
i think it's very very important to have
a clear vision about
what are the strategic topics that we
will discuss
at the level of the european council
between today
and june next year this is
a concrete proposal that i put on the
table knowing that
this agenda will be flexible based on
the circumstances probably
we will adapt our way of working and i
intend
to continue to try to develop a strong
preparation for each european council
we have experienced the last month
smaller formats smaller video conference
in preparation of some
some difficult topics we used this tool
smaller formats for example in order to
prepare
our position regarding china we did the
same regarding
turkey in the eastern ireland we think
it's a it's a
an effective approach in order to be
certain that we have
a space for real interactivity political
interactivity
among among the the leaders then
today we agreed formally
our conclusions on the digital and
single market
this is a very strong signal this is a
very
important step that we are making today
european
foreign
foreign
we had a short update about
the negotiations the the ongoing
process of negotiations with the
european parliament
in order to implement what we have
decided in july
the mff the on resources and
the recovery fund we will have the
occasion in the next days
uh to be involved in order to try to
make progress we know that there are
some difficult topics
between the member states and with the
european parliament that we need to
solve we note that we know that our
agreement in july
was a political package and it's very
essential to be able
as soon as possible to deliver to
implement what we have
decided it's a question of credibility
that i feel
a strong political will to make progress
and to be able to implement the mff
and the recovery fund but will continue
to work
very hard in order to reach this goal
and finally
just one word about brexit just an
information session we had the occasion
to have an
update by ursula and also an analysis
by the irish prime minister
but we didn't open the debate today
because we
you know that we'll have the occasion uh
in october during our next meeting
to have a more substantial exchange of
views
and we will take into consideration the
possible developments between today and
the next
european council we trust the commission
we trust michelle barnier
we have a clear european position we are
united
we are very calm we have expressed very
clearly
the last week what we think about the
current situation and we will have the
occasion
in october to tackle this important
topic
it is
thank you have the floor madam president
merci
thank you very much um it was very good
that
the leaders decided to devote time to
our collective response to the covered
pandemic the epidemiological situation
is worrying
so we must stay very focused to
avoid a return to the dire situation we
experienced last spring
and we can only overcome both the
pandemic and its consequences
if we work together member states and eu
institutions
and therefore this debate was very
deep diving and three things from this
debate stand out first of all
progress on vaccines is the key to a
long-term solution to this crisis
we're making good progress the
commission has already concluded
two advanced purchase agreements and it
is negotiating
five more and we are in discussions with
four more companies so this is on a good
track
because through this these advanced
purchase
agreements we are investing
in production capacities right now
to ensure that the access to the
vaccines is
there for the european citizens so
ramping up the production lines
buying now raw material and all the
necessary ingredients
that you need to ramp up then the
production once we have the vaccine
the second point is the vaccine strategy
whom to vaccinate first the commission
has put forward a blueprint for vaccine
plan before the summer break and good
news is that it has been adopted now
with the health security committee so we
can move
on with council recommendation based on
this blueprint
and thirdly we discuss that we must do a
better job in coordinating our
assessment and the measures
to be taken across member states
in short this is i would call it the
color code
so what does it mean if a region is red
or orange or green and what
are the common rules for that
weeks ago we tabled a proposal for
accounts recommendations on this
and i urge the member states to find an
agreement on it now because
it increases transparency and clarity
for the european people
to know how to move on in different
regions of europe
the other topic are the council
conclusions um
on the single market and the digital
three pillars stand out here three
pillars of competitiveness
and indeed prosperity first of all a
well-functioning single market is
crucial for us we should remember that
trade
between member states amounts to roughly
25
of gdp and that 60 million jobs
depend on it second
a competitive industry industry provides
37 million jobs in the european union
and
two-thirds of our exports
and of course thirdly the need for
successful
digital transition discussions on how to
improve the functioning of the single
markets
have been ongoing for years the issues
are well known
two stand out in particular first of all
remaining barriers notably in the area
of services
and second problems with implementation
that deprive companies from the benefits
of a large
and deep market which is our wealth the
source of our wealth
to accelerate the pace in this area the
commission will present a first
monitoring report
early next year and then we will build
on this to work concretely
with member states and stakeholders to
resolve the problems
companies face on a daily basis
with regards to industry the priority is
to join forces
in key strategic areas and ensure our
industry can compete
on a global scale as you know we
presented our new
industry strategy in march to ensure
industry can lead the twin green and
digital transition
clearly the last six months have
accelerated the transformation and
changed a lot
supply chains have been disrupt the lack
of production facilities in the european
union
for certain critical products became an
issue
remote digital working methods became
the norm
for millions of workers so to take
all this into account we will update
the industry strategy in the first half
of the next year it will be an
opportunity to take stock
of where we are with industrial
alliances for
key technologies such as batteries
microelectronics or hydrogen and efforts
to improve our resilience
such as on raw materials
but of course for our work on these
alliances to bear fruit
we need to ensure a proper level playing
field
in this respect two priorities stand out
first of all we are carrying out a
comprehensive review
on how to adapt eu competition rules
we need to make them fit for purpose in
a globalized and digital world
and secondly we're working at full speed
on legislative proposals
on foreign subsidies from third
countries
we know that these foreign subsidies
from third countries can significantly
distort the functioning functioning of
our single market
and disadvantage eu market operators
finally on the digital transition
europe clearly needs to up its game
as i said last week in the european
parliament we must make this europe's
digital decade there are three
priorities the first one is data
we need to play our strength in the area
of
industrial data the quality of this data
and the quantity will quadruple in the
next
five years and we need to
enable companies to harness this
potential at the moment being 80 percent
of these industrial data are never used
once
so we will work on two strengths to have
the access
for european companies european
universities
researchers to these industrial data in
europe we will create common data spaces
in which researchers universities and
companies can access and collaborate for
example in the energy or healthcare
sector
to help unlock these hidden data
and second building a european cloud as
part of next generation u based on gaia
x
the second pillar in the digital decade
is artificial intelligence with a
tremendous
potential but it needs rules to ensure
proper use and oversight
so the commission will propose a law to
this effect
next year and we also aim to soon
propose a secure
european digital identity
because we think that you should be able
to do
many many things on the digital um in
the digital topic
here in europe with your european
identity
from paying taxes to renting a car you
name it
and the third topic is the
infrastructure
proper data connections we should not
forget that
particular um on
if we focus on the 40 of people who live
in rural areas
who do still not have access to fast
broadband
that here we have to step up and improve
it's a question of equal
opportunity and this is why we will
focus our investments on
secure connectivity on the expansion of
5g
6g and fiber and
therefore we will push forward this
digital decade
while investing 20 percent of next
generation eu
on the digital because it's about
europe's digital
sovereignty we have to work on that
thank you
thank you madam president we will take a
couple of questions
and switch on your cameras please um if
you want to
ask a question to one of the presidents
um i'll first start with lily bayer from
politico
lilly you have the floor
good good afternoon thank you very much
um i have a question that goes
both to both presidents um the question
is both poland and hungary have
indicated that if the proposed rule of
law mechanism
to link the distribution of eu funding
to rule of law criteria
is not concluded to their liking they
will block
the own resources decision which is
needed in order for the recovery fund
to become operational so my question for
you today is
did this come up in discussions with
leaders do you have a plan b
or how do you plan on convincing poland
and hungary to come on board
thank you yeah yes we we had a very
short distinction on this topic
because it was important for us to
listen to the update
presented by the german
president of uh of the council by angela
merkel
and it's not a secret it's not a
surprise
we know that it's key to implement as
soon as possible what we have decided
uh in july and we know that the creation
of rule of law
is a difficult topic it was in july a
difficult topic it was a sensitive topic
but in july
we took the decision to make the
traditionality with the governance and
with
the creation of a rule of law and then
we will continue in the next days to
work very hard
uh with the member states but also with
the european parliament
on this uh on this topic uh i know that
it will be a difficult decision it will
be a difficult debate
but i think and i hope uh that we will
have
together all the member states with uh
the members of the open parliament it
will
that will have the common political will
in order to find
a solution because it's very important
for the european future
to be able to ratify as soon as possible
in the national parliaments but also to
get the agreement of the european
parliament
can be very brief indeed it was a report
of the german presidency
on i would call it the state of
negotiations with the european
parliament at the moment being
these negotiations are ongoing charles
michel has mentioned
all the diffi different and difficult
issues
there was no in-depth discussion because
it is
work and progress and when there is a
result to be debated
then this will be the time to do to go
in depth
thank you
please you're next yes hi uh good
afternoon i have a question
for each uh president and first for
president vandalia and i just wondered
uh
you will meet boris johnson tomorrow
a video conference with him and i just
want to know what's going to be the most
important thing will you address
specifically the internal market bill
first and foremost or will you start
negotiating
looking where we can go on the free
trade talks
and i would also like to know what your
assessment your latest assessment is
on the progress that we now have seen so
far
and then i have a question for council
president michelle
and it's about u.s president trump who
has tested positive
for covet and i just wondered what
lessons we can draw from uh
from this on how we should deal with the
pandemic
thank you madam president yes um
thank you uh indeed uh there are two
strands work strands at the moment being
the one is the implementation of the
withdrawal agreement
and as you know the draft internal
market bill is heavily contradicting
some of the provisions in this
withdrawal agreement
mainly when it comes to the protocol of
ireland northern ireland
and as you know we asked the
uk government to withdraw this within a
month
this didn't take place so we launched an
infringement procedure
this is going its way the infringement
procedure
process is a part of the dispute
settlement
of the withdrawal agreement and the
second trend indeed are the overall
negotiations and
my phone called it actually is going to
be a video conference with boris johnson
uh will serve to take stock of the
negotiations at that
time and to have a look at
the time coming up i will then report to
council
in sum your third part of the question
is we want a deal
because we think it is better to have a
deal as
neighbors also on top in these
covet times with devastating impact on
the economies
it is good to have a deal but not at any
price
and mainly the topic of the level
playing field
how can we make sure that it exists
between both economies
and the question of fisheries are very
difficult so
we will see how we'll progress on that
yes about donald trump
test it positive of course
we all wish with him a speedy recovery
but of course i will not personally i
will not give
a health advice
we have another question now for
gavin lee from bbc news gavin
hi hello can you hear me okay yes please
state your question first
for both of you could you just explain a
little why
president lukashenko wasn't included in
the sanctions given that the uk and
canada believe that this was a point
to include him in sanctions and a second
brief
uh follow-up question on brexit um on
the eu
uk trade deal i know we've heard about
your your conversation with boris
johnson tomorrow
uh president on the line but could you
also give a sense you know the uk
side are still saying they can see a
light at the end of the tunnel
can you see a light at the end of the
tunnel on talks
maybe about uh the sanctions on on
belarus we took the decision to
implement and today it's done like i
announced yesterday today it's done we
implemented
this entrance we have a list with 40
names and you know that
in europe there's a clear process in
order to prepare the list what we did
there was indeed a debate uh on on
lucashenko on the list or not and we
took the decision after the debate
to follow the list uh proposed uh
at the the ministerial uh level but of
course we will follow uh
closely the situation and you know that
we are in favor
of an inclusive dialogue on belarus and
in belarus
and we hope that it will be possible for
the oec
to play a real and efficient role in
order to improve the situation
so um on the uk
question um we have in germany saying
that goes when villa is in weak and
translated it's more or less where there
is a will
there is a way and we should not forget
that we have made progress on many many
different fields
but of course the most difficult ones
are still completely open
and this is mainly also the question of
the level playing field
because this is the question of fairness
so if you want full access to the single
market
you have to a certain amount abide
to the rules that are the fairness rules
within
the single market and questions like
state aid for example
are questions of fairness and of
competitiveness
advantages that you give to companies or
not and there are rules that have to be
worked out we also would have to work on
a mechanism
where over time we
when things change there's an alignment
and if there are problems and
difficulties there must be a dispute
settlement
mechanism so you see from my words
there's still
a lot of work to do but it is as i say a
matter of fairness
and if you want to have the full access
to the single market
these fairness rules must apply and
therefore this is so difficult
but overall where there is a will there
is a way
so i think we should intensify
the negotiations because it's worth
working hard on it a second point on the
withdrawal agreement
as it is it can be implemented
implemented
and i call again on everybody to
really work hard to implement it is so
important
to have this clarified we have the whole
text we have the possibilities now
to sort out the difficulties in on the
island of
ireland and in good faith keeping
the good friday agreement this is very
important this can be done too
we'll take a last question now from uh
from sam flanging
from the ft sam are you with us
i am thanks very much uh i'm afraid of a
follow-up on brexit again
um madame bottom line you mentioned the
idea of the need to intensify
negotiations
um does that imply that you do see the
prospect of now entering a
negotiating tunnel or going sumarin
in order to um to reach the possibility
of that deal
and i want to just more broadly what
what are the key things you'll be asking
boris johnson when you speak to him what
do you want to hear from him
i mean do you believe that the uk
government is united and actually
wanting a trade deal
thank you so um
i don't like the term tunnel to be
honest because uh
it's it's a weird association so
intensify is we're running out of time
it's
uh i think uh around 100 days till the
end of the year
so uh it's worth to step up now
um as always in these uh um
vcs or telephone calls
i go in them in an open mind we want to
take stock
and we want to exchange positions
so i will not communicate to boris
johnson beforehand via media
what my expectations are
thank you and this concludes our press
conference of today may i remind you
that the leader's agenda which was
proposed by the president of the
european council
is on our website so please consult that
now
thanks a lot and see you soon
you